في هذه القطعة من الأرض التي تبلغ مساحتها 10 فدان والمليئة
بـ 2200 شجرة بلوط مقدسة ، يمكنك العثور على
أحد أكثر أنواع الفطر ندرة في
العالم ولكنه غير مرئي فوق سطح
الأرض للعثور عليه ، فأنت بحاجة إلى
ملاح خاص
يجتمع لولو وهي واحدة من
المكونات الرئيسية في صيد الكمأة ، لذا فإن
الكمأة تحت الأرض لذا لا يمكنك
رؤيتها ، لذلك نحن نعلم الكلاب أن تحدد
مكانًا ليس لدي حتى واحدة من هذه
العلب الصغيرة وهذه العلب الصغيرة ، نعم أيها
الفتاة الطيبة بها قطع من الكمأة و
لذلك نقوم بتعليم الكلاب العثور على هذه
الأشياء في الأصل ، ثم في النهاية تقوم
بدفنها تحت الأرض وستشتم الكلاب في
بساتين الكمأة
رائحة الكمأة التي ستذهب إليها ، وسوف
يشيرون إليها إما بالنقر بقدمها
عليها أو بالحفر قليلاً و  ثم
يضعون أنوفهم
عليها وهكذا نعرف ما هو الكمأة
هناك عندما تفكر في الكمأ الأسود الشتوي
الذي قد تفكر فيه في جنوب
فرنسا ولكن الآن يمكنك إضافة قصدير المعبد
إلى القائمة ، فلنأخذ قفزة من الإيمان
ودعنا نجربها بريان و  دينيس الركبة  إذا
كان الأمر يتطلب صبرًا وعملًا شاقًا
لزراعة هذا المحصول ، فقد زرعنا الأشجار
في عام 2015
ونتعلم أن الدورة العادية
هي حوالي ست إلى عشر سنوات ، لذا فقد مرت
ست سنوات تقريبًا
وللحصول على هذا الحجم من الكمأة بهذه
السرعة  تعلم أنها مثيرة حقًا ولكن الوقت
ليس هو العقبة الوحيدة عند زراعة
هذه الفطريات ، من المعروف أن الكمأة الشتوية السوداء
نادرة بسبب مقدار
الاهتمام الذي يجب أن يتم
توجيهه لزراعتها
بالري ثم إبعاد
كل من
القوارض الغازية والأشياء الأخرى عن
من بستان الكمأة بعد ست سنوات ،
كانت قفزة الإيمان التي أخذها دينيس وبريان
تستحق العناء ، لقد وجدنا هذه الأربعة
فقط في غضون ساعات قليلة اليوم ،
لذا من يعرف عدد
المطاعم التي سنجدها ونعم المطاعم هذه مطلوبة بشدة ،
نعم  حوالي ألف دولار
للرطل في أخبار تمبلتون كيمبرلي كروز ksby